paquet de liens non plus entre étrangers
et personnes radicaliser ce qu'il
faudrait monsieur le président c'est
être fermes sont nos principes sur la
liberté d'expression
quand j'entends le président votre
groupe ce matin sur rtl dire je cite
monsieur retailleau qui donne des leçons
de fermeté à tout bout de champ oui à la
caricature mais avec une forme de
respect et ben non monsieur le président
retailleau la liberté d'expression elle
est totale même quand ça gêne
elle concerne toutes les religions et
c'est avec ce genre de format monsieur
ciotti vous a d'ailleurs corrigé
monsieur abad vous à corriger et oui
vous devrez retirer vos propos parce que
je crois monsieur prison retailleau que
ce avec des propos comme ceux ci qu on
n'encourage pas le président de la
république et le gouvernement être ferme
comme nous le sommes depuis ce matin
monsieur monsieur le président buffet
[Musique]